I mean I have such affinity for
Northwest Indiana but it is the
stepchild of Chicago it goes Chicago and
then Northwest Indiana is right there
and if you said hey I'm from Northwest
Indiana people in Chicago would be like
where's that you're like it's 10 it's 15
minutes away but it was such kind of
like the area of riffraff I could always
tell when there were people from
Northwest Indiana because I do meet and
greets after the show and they would be
in sweatpants it would be like Saturday
night and they're like showing up in
sweatpants but they're good sweats
they're good they're good they're like
you know this I'm not at work ah yeah
I'm going to a show yeah